what does hisoka do now hisoka's destiny
is ultimately one of two things death or
boredom he either dies like for real
this time he dies fighting a strong
battle opponent and probably releasing
his most powerful orgasm before
releasing his life from this Mortal
plane that oroka beats everyone and has
no one left to Peak his interest as our
horny battle clown is left lingering
simply Suffering From Success this world
mate it just isn't made for someone like
yoker anymore but he can do something to
change that and here's what the thing is
from this point and I am completely
serious about this hisoka's best option
would be to launch an impromptu
political career and become chairman of
the hunter Association this makes so
much more sense than it has any right to
because Hoka already acts as kind of his
own chairman isoka has a history of
using the hunter Association as testing
grounds for his own personal exams once
during the actual Hunter exam and then
again during the election when he only
showed up to grade the hunters with his
special rating system and this is the
way for hisoka to mold the world into
his own personal Paradise not only that
but he has viable political support
within the association a lot more than
you may realize and a genuine path to
chairm so firstly let's establish why
this is the correct move the hunter
Association is a completely independent
organization they're not under the
control of any specific government
however with that said the hunter
Association is an organization that is
somewhat at the command of the V5 now
the V6 I guess because they were the
ones that seemed to have the authority
to order netro to take the Chimera ant
extermination Mission we only want one
thing the Swift extermination of a
dangerous species we're not the experts
here you are we just want them
exterminated as quickly as possible with
Neto noting that the outcome was that
the hunter Association would take the
full Fallout of the Chimera ant outbreak
this was the V5 hiring the hunter
Association but it was a request that
really couldn't be refused so it's not
as a political as it's made out to be
however and I mean this without
hyperbole the hunter Association does
effectively rule the world of the top
100 richest people in the world 60 of
them are professional Hunters 60% of the
world's richest people are members of
the hunter Association and those 60
people have significant Authority within
the association many of them are in top
positions but also membership of the
hunter Association is calculated at just
over 600 so on their own they have 10%
of voting power and it's with this
unparalleled Authority that the chairman
sets the agenda not just for the hunter
Association but for the entire world in
fact one of the reasons why the hunter
exam was such a brutal affair with a
very real chance of death for applicants
was because that was then chairman nro's
agenda for the world his desire was to
push himself and find strong opponents
sounds a bit familiar really doesn't it
Isaac netro valued strength Above All
Else and so the whole association was
constructed according to power one of
the key selection criteria for the
zodiacs was the ability to spar with
netro whenever he saw fit and for
someone who oversaw the hunter
Association for at least half a century
Neto directly shaped the world we live
in the strong granted High status and
their Pursuits were prioritized and we
can now directly contrast that against
che's tenure as chairman che's values
are much less morally gray than netos
cheel is far more academically inclined
and prioritizes intelligence as well as
stability and as one of her first acts
cheel radically reformed the hunter exam
previously neto's first phase was a
purely physical test to run 80 km
through a tunnel that in his mind was
the absolute base that a hunter needed
to meet meanwhile che's first phase was
a psychological evaluation designed to
eliminate any candidate who held ill
intent towards the association as well
as the upcoming Dark Continent Voyage
but if netro was still in charge he
probably would have said no no let them
cook it's always more interesting to
have people who try to undermine me and
I have no doubt that if cheel survives
the Dark Continent Voyage then she will
probably usher in something of a global
Renaissance one where the world shifts
its focus away from strength and more
towards ideas and Innovation so all of
this is a is a very long-winded way of
saying that hisoka's best move would be
to become chairman of the hunter
Association because then he gets to set
the agenda and if that agenda is sex
fighting then so be it but who in their
right mind would vote for Hoka well for
that matter who out of their right mind
would vote for him Hoka didn't even vote
for himself during the chairman election
in fact he didn't vote for anyone but
this is where things get very
interesting this isn't something a lot
of people notice because the voting in
the election and it's frustratingly
layered and convoluted I mean there's a
total of nine voting rounds that Togashi
subjects us to but I want to draw
everyone's attention to the very first
round of voting where hisoka actually
received two votes and thus was ranked
in 35th place to be the next chairman of
the hunter Association who voted for
hisoka maybe bisy because she thought he
was hot maybe pariston just to be a
troll ILY may have also done so for
whatever reason some people have also
suggested shellock but even at this
stage the Phantom troop were not huge
Hoka supporters and also he was absent
from the election the only person we
know for a fact didn't vote for Hoka is
hisoka himself because this is the round
of voting where he inserted the blank
sheet what this tells me is that somehow
isoka has organic support within the
organization whether it's troll support
or people who actually want him to
become the chairman it doesn't matter
what matters is that he's not starting
from zero his political career already
has some Grassroots momentum and two
votes it sounds like not many but it's
not anything to scoff at either most of
the top 10 candidates in this round of
voting got barely above 10 votes so Hoka
is well and truly in this race now in
regards to the hunt of voter base
remember that most hunters within the
association Rose to their positions
under Neto they're the Old Guard and
they may not be pleased with the
direction in which cheel takes the
organization because it's almost
antithetical to Isaac neto's principles
isoku and netro are not shockingly
different people they both have
extremely similar values and desires for
life which is to find the strong people
and then to fight the strong people the
only real difference is that hisoka's
drive is tied towards his own sexual
gratification and to be fair we don't
know that netos was not tied to that he
just might have had a much more Stern o
face but there are many people within
the association who would be in favor of
a more strength-based approach a sort of
make the hunter Association great again
campaign and here's the thing because
Isaac netro didn't discriminate by
intention it means that the hunter
Association has ended up with a lot of
less than morally upstanding individuals
Hunters are not necessarily the good
guys in this world in fact many of them
are frankly reprehensible and there's a
lot of them pariston Hill is one of
those individuals he put on a nice kind
show but this didn't fool anyone within
the Association pariston was a known
quantity of power hungry selfishness and
yet throughout the election he retained
a solid roughly 40% of support from the
voting hunters and ultimately he did
succeed in becoming the chairman so
hisoka's path to this position is
nowhere near unfeasible he might not
have the political instincts of pariston
but roughly half the association of
terrible people with terrible ideas
terrible ideas that Hoka would
absolutely facilitate and if those
people see someone campaigning on their
sick desires then why not vote for him I
genuinely think Hoka could win
especially with a solid campaign team
and some alliances left over from the
pariston era but it's only after he wins
that the real work begins because we've
got to completely reform the hunter exam
hoker is of course a natural examiner
it's a bit of a misconception that he
was a candidate for the 287th exam
because from his perspective isoka was
the one conducting the exam isoka very
consistently uses the hunter Association
to host his own tests for non-consensual
candidates in the misty Wetlands he SOA
tested his candidates on one simple
thing fight or flight and even though
Hoka himself acknowledged that running
was the smarter option he was grading
candidates based on who stayed to fight
him only two people passed this test
Leorio who stood his ground and gone who
wasn't part of the initial test but who
interrupted it and in fact for that he
got bonus points isoka was so impressed
that he even carried the unconscious
Leorio to the end of the actual exam
stage meanwhile kopa failed this exam
because he just kept running and that's
one of the many reasons why of all of
the characters hoker expresses little to
no interest in ever fighting kopa
because of this moment right here that's
where he lost hisoka's interest so I
imagine that the first round of chairman
hisoka's Hunter exam would be very
similar hoker emerges in front of all
the candidates S as a group of them
closest to him UTS something smug like
wow so many dropouts already this isn't
making me erect at all and from there
it's simple everyone who runs away from
him fails the exam but everyone willing
to stay and fight moves on to phase two
and Hoka isn't going to waste any time
here if a candidate pass is his initial
phase then they need to learn n ASAP got
to plant those fight seeds so that he
can harvest the delicious battle crops
and the fastest way to reach his goal is
to initiate all of the candidates this
is of course the quick and dirty path to
unlocking AA control it's very taboo and
generally nen users have to undergo
lengthy periods of meditation to unlock
their Aura and among many of the reasons
why initiation is not an accepted
practice is because it often results in
permanent injury and death so the second
phase test boils down to don't die if
you do then then that's on you and if
you don't then I want you on me and this
is pretty much directly taken from the
unspoken Heavens Arena laws when a
candidate reaches the 200th floor they
are initiated whether they want to be or
not for the surviving applicants they
will then receive a comprehensive nen
education from genuinely one of the
greatest nen Shooters on the planet we
often forget that Hoka is one of the
leading nen academics in this world he
is a genuine Genius of VOR control and
capable of dissecting complex Ora
formula mid battle even being able to
quickly diagnose n affinities without
not even having seen someone usora yet
isoka is also a very willing teacher to
those he sees potential in isoka he very
little forgone and in fact even gave him
an in-depth lesson during the fight at
Heaven's arena in fact there was even a
short exam at the end when Hoka ason to
figure out when he detached bongon and
the reason for this openness is because
why hide anything the more knowledge
that he soak a hordes the slower the
growth of his crops and he may even go
so far as to facilitate development of
their n abilities this is probably the
end of the hunter exam from here on
candidates issued licenses they granted
jobs and freedom and monies and such but
this is not the end of hisoka's exam in
the long run Hoka needs to water and
fertilizes crops by exposing them to
high levels of danger as chairman he
will no doubt accept incredibly deadly
jobs and send in Hunters who are wildly
unprepared pressure creates diamonds
after all isoka may even host annual
Association tournaments to continue
compounding that growth he can also have
his own set of zodiacs Who present the
most sensual opportunities to him and
then it's finally time we've prepared
enough and there's a few different
harvesting methods that Hoka could
choose the first is the sneaky method of
assigning a hunter a mission to kill him
or an even sneakier mission where hunter
gets assigned a decoy Mission and hisoka
unexpectedly appears to challenge set
Hunter Hoka is of course a very sneaky
man and despite his Heaven Arena
appearances he really does enjoy his
privacy it would also stop any
unnecessary objections and political
Fallout within the association however
if we want to to be blunt and public
about it isoka may even set a condition
that anyone is free to become chairman
however to do so they must kill him and
having undergone Hoka system those who
rise to the top will no doubt be on the
power hungrier side of things whatever
the case the intent behind the
organization is to breed people who are
capable of giving hisoka a thrill like
the donut machine that perpetually feeds
Homer on that one episode of The
Simpsons hisoka's purpose would be to
build an infinite machine that can
entertain him for all eternity or until
he finally creates that one person who
can bury him for good and that's why
hisoka should be the next chairman of
the Hunter associ ation